Lance Bass is on in the afternoon and  then I have banged him right I did yeah  we did something we did stuff you banged  him or he bang you we we're not talking  about that really my god  um don't you think that mean that's a  radio Andy radio Andy yeah I want to  already played out enough I wonder what  you and Lance did actually I mean when  you got down to it the you know Lance is  he's cute  why did you not like hook up with him  cuz I've been an interesting coupling  like you and Lance yeah I think it ran  we were on we it was like a boat mance  we were both on boats there right in  tandem sounds very gay the way that I'm  doing that hey listen you and you were  driving best around for a couple days  and and he's great I mean he's a big  deal right - I mean like hey I'm with  Lance Bass that's right that's a score  yeah you know what I mean yeah hey I'm  I'm [ __ ] LANs bad hey yeah  everybody's a boy bander yeah why not